you have a new uh formula for coming up  with porn names there's of course the  classic formula yeah which is uh your  childhood pet plus the street you grew  up on right what's yours uh pebbles  canard oh  i'm not kidding yeah all right  i'm not even making a joke i had a i was  like three and i got a cat and i said  call it pebbles  and then i grew up on canard road so  pebbles connecticut what about you oh  mine is buster service ramp  [Laughter]  it's just  very nice so we have a new improved  formula if you do have you know like  pebbles canard or buster service ramp  you can take your uh your favorite  alcohol beverage plus your biggest  insecurity  oh that's weird well what's yours  uh oh there's so many  yeah appletini bad sex  what's yours  uh it would probably be then um  uh tequila shirtless